an explanation of mental suggestion so
Mike I want you to go ahead and grab the
Jo both hands on top strongly and just
push the jail flat to the ground just
push it straight down nice and light
pushes the job straight down to the
ground okay now what I'm going to do is
I'm going to extend my key into the joke
and then I would like to go ahead and
slowly begin to push the Jo down to the
ground what you can straight down to the
ground push it all your mind pushing all
your mind pushing over the ground push
yourself push it down okay so um now
first seeing that you might think one of
two things either this is all made up
right so I said Mike pretend to act like
super to dad like this is hard I want
you see when I do this Oh Mike was
pretending okay that's not what this was
okay the second thing you might think it
is is I have magic powers I stick this
out here I extend my gene and then a lot
of magic it might push it down any kid
I've done he's really pushing as hard as
you can but I can't seem to bring it
down okay that's not what's happening
what's happening is simply mental
suggestion I gave Mike a parameter are a
number of parameters in which he can
operate and then I simply change the
factors so when we're doing this it
seems like he can't push it down to him
but he's actually doing it all to
himself
so when I stick the Jo out first things
I don't like to stick both hands on top
okay this aligns him properly so I
already conditioned by I've already told
him you need to listen to what I say in
order for this to work the next thing I
tell Mike is he has to push this black
down to the ground so I make sure to
push it flat down to the ground yeah if
you saw how easy that was so he knows
that's easy
and I'm also conditioned to know he must
push the dough flat that means he has to
keep the joke level to the ground so
what I tell Mike to really begin pushing
all I do is simply tilt the Jo back and
forth let it open once again all I'm
doing it bringing is up all I'm doing is
this very small very small I'm doing
this now one has to compensate for this
because Mike knows that she has to push
it flat so when it begins to push
I simply move the Joe's slightly right
because Mike's strong and he's shaking
it you can't even tell what I'm doing so
I've given Mike some parameters he's got
to push it flattens gotta have his hands
on top so when Mike begins working it
gets working against himself I can hold
it here all day I'm not doing any work
Mike's holding it up for me and he's
working his hands against each other
this is a very easy thing to do so if my
didn't have to operate within the
parameters if I didn't begin to push it
flat to the ground but instead I could
push it down any way possible when I
begin to tilt the joke Michael just push
however he can push right there Mike
push the dirt on the ground he might
even push against me and down right so
they're like push the Joe down but
because Mike believes he has to push it
black to the ground he will work in a
method to push it flat to the ground
I simply sabotage that as he pushes flat
I tilt the Joe he's working against
himself as hard as he can and I'm pretty
much effortlessly holding the joke it's
just simply mental suggestion hey so
this has nothing to do with amazing
amounts of power it has nothing to do
with trickery I'm not trying to trick
anyone what's happening is really
happening Mike really trying to push it
down it's just I gave Mike a construct
to operate with him and once he believes
he has to operate within this construct
he'll do his damnedest to try and make
it work so my explanation of mental
suggestion with the Joe trick